was the case but someone who definitely
knows nothing about the pre-computer era
is with us now fabiano caruana after a
smashing victory a must win game if he's
going to keep his campaign alive fabi uh
this game was
you came out with a new idea it looked
like right away you wanted at least some
imbalanced position to play against your
opponent as you really had to
win this game if you're going to still
be in the hunt
um
yeah first of all i take some slight
issue with what you said about having no
idea
about the pre-computer dates because i
grew up without computers
really
um
wait how aren't you like 22.
something like that
a bit older
you're 29 years old if i'm not mistaken
so
you were like nine and ten what were you
doing back then
preparing for opponents i mean there
were computers but um i grew up playing
american opens two games a day
games weren't really prepared for and
certainly
uh we didn't have powerful hardware or
or software was also not well developed
then to the way that we have now what
age are you talking about right there so
you're talking i mean 12 year 11 12
years old
until i was like i don't know mid teens
yeah
i mean there were computers but it
wasn't
uh it wasn't anywhere close to now where
uh you know they
they just told you pretty much just told
you the answer in a position
um
back then it was like you know you you
work with an early version of fritz and
it says
e4 c5 white is winning
uh things have changed a bit well we
were talking about matchups in
particular like how do you prepare
against specific opponents when you had
to prepare against specific specific
opponents at that point weren't there
databases i believe chess base was
already out by that time not the
evaluations of the position
but
you could you could say i know this
guy's openings christian carrillo i know
what he plays
yeah there were um
yeah we used chess base
but uh until i i started playing in
european
tournaments opens and close tournaments
preparation wasn't a big factor and then
yeah preparation became a thing where
you you go through a database and you
figure out what your opponent does
usually people had more limited
repertoires back then now it's it's much
harder to prepare because everyone plays
everything
everyone's booked up everyone's well
prepared
so it's a lot harder these days to to be
to keep
on top of openings and preparation at a
high level
this preparation that you played in this
game what made you go for this direction
yeah i didn't expect this line at all
because he he usually played d5 um
instead of bishop b4 uh he didn't have
so many games but that seemed to be
uh his main opening and bishop b4 came
as a surprise
um
but i i do have a bit of experience in
these lines
the thing is
i think he was unfamiliar with the
nuances because of knight d5 immediately
then bishop c5
is a much better version
instead of bishop g2
oops sorry
sorry you mean you should have played
knight d no this is a better version for
black after bishop c5 i see sorry if b4
now there's knight b4
knight b4 and e4 and it's kind of
crucial that
um
let's say white's knight retreats and
black takes on f3 and white can't take
back with the piece so the structure
gets damaged
um
and that that's the reason why
the move order i played is better
um
so what should he have done bishop g2
you should have not castled or
no no castle is fine and knight d5 and
the main move is e4 i mean bishop c5 is
not a bad move
but this is sort of the
b4 is supposed to be the downside the
critical move yeah
i imagine you had something prepared
against this
well i played against e4 many times so
yeah i i had a pretty good idea of the
line but it is a very good line for
black
all right so
where was his fatal error
uh as he put a bishop on a5 were you
surprised by this because we were yeah i
thought he would play bishop f8
i would castle and
he can play d5 now or even d6 is a
better version because the bishop
it looks like the bishop is good on b6
but it just gets blocked by e3 so it's
much better on f8 and also if he plays
d5 it's much better on f8
okay so at least we understand a little
something about chess
because we didn't like that bishop of a5
move and so then he started looking like
he was getting into a lot of trouble
maybe primarily because of the
disjointed pieces i think his main
mistake was playing d6
um
if he plays d5 i i don't
know if white is any better i would take
on d5 he takes probably with the knight
and i was going to play knight c5 and
it's a bit of a
tense position
if i get d4 in the center then i'm
better but he has b6 bishop a6 it was
kind of sharp
um
so yeah i was more worried about this d6
came as a very pleasant
uh surprise and then i thought
it's a nice position um
yeah at some point after e4 i assumed
i'm borderline winning
d5 i i wasn't sure if this was a sack or
a blunder
but maybe he has nothing better because
b5 i take an h4 and he's actually
um either losing the bishop
or
like b5 a b a b
h4
and the problem is if bc i take an h5 so
he his bishop gets tracked so he has to
play a very ugly move h5
um
and that's not very good for him
definitely bad so so maybe it was a good
pawn sacrifice because i i really
struggled after d5 to find the right way
and i don't think i did it
it looked like you were you were close
to winning you know no it must be
winning but
i it didn't feel easy
like at first i thought i'll take on c7
and get the center and but then my
center remains weak um
i didn't see a way to consolidate this
yeah he'll play like rook let's say bd8
um
probably bd8 so he doesn't so i don't
get d4 very easily
because now i don't think i can play d4
so i have to make it a tough well now
queen c4 i guess
um
yeah this is this is not good so i have
to do something which
wasn't easy for me to see so i i
preferred to keep the knight
um
which is double edged i mean it's a very
good knight but also
his historical square bishop is uh is
the only good thing about his position
so
i don't know it felt a bit messy once
his b-pawn started to get rolling
so what then
i mean it seemed though that you started
to control the game but somehow it went
from control to just dead loss for him
yeah i mean this it seems like he was
doing the right thing i was at least
happy that his bishop on f7 is
is borderline dead
and his b-pawn is controlled
but um
yeah i don't know i was thinking he
should try to find a way to trade queens
but i i don't
know exactly how
yeah right here suddenly there's like
yeah this advantage jump maybe bishop c5
yeah something went wrong with bishop c5
the engine doesn't like your guys moves
but that it's usually overestimating
then you put a knight on g7 which
everybody
who was smiling at your knight is
you know you underpromoted to a bishop
one game now you put a knight on g7 in
this game it looks like you're was this
was this for effect or you felt like
that was absolutely the best move no i
thought it was a great night
um
i think is the knight on g7 with the
pawn h6 is kind of a
common pattern not okay not common but
it's it's not it's not a completely
unknown pattern
and it's just the knight is cemented
there and it can always escape by uh e6
and the h6 pawn basically means black's
king has made it for the rest of the
game
um
okay there was only i think bishop d4
um there was only one important line if
he took on e5 after e5
um
because i have to take on f7 and okay i
spent some time on this
because of this line queen f7 rook f8
and i think i have to play 96 otherwise
it's probably mate
and he takes i take on d8 like rook f2
knight e6
um
okay it's not
too difficult but
it's at least important that my king
escapes there's no
threats in the end game and um
and my d-pawn will run
so
important point let's just go back a
couple of moves in this line where you
played rook
f8 uh you made the point 96's four so
it actually like queen e6 for example
we should point out why you duck this
line because of i don't know maybe
bishop f2 king h1 is good but i just
didn't
consider this because i was concerned
about a rook h4 kind of but yeah but i
love you through defending h3 but i
don't know bishop
like it's
you don't want to do this right because
i don't have any threats against this
king for the moment right so
yeah i'd rather avoid this
absolutely so then you managed to finish
off the game uh with some style uh
sacrificing the exchange and also then
getting a chance to sacrifice on f5
beautiful finish great game
uh it still only puts you at plus one
but you're only half a point behind the
leaders as nobody was able to
to land a blow despite having some great
chances there are two rounds to go are
you looking at
the comebacks being on
well it's probably the first moment in
the tournament when it feels like
i have some sort of shot um i mean
besides very early on
uh yeah i thought that wesley
i wasn't sure what was going on but he
was a piece i didn't think danya had
enough compensation
um
but i don't know i
it was a very complicated game so i it
was kind of fortunate i guess that uh
that nobody else pulled ahead even more
will you be going for it tomorrow
yeah i think i i have to
all right those are the fighting words
we want to hear don't forget i picked
you to win the tournament no pressure
it's all about my pick no problem versus
these guys congrats on a great win see
you tomorrow thank you well done tabby
indeed that